نظره تشاؤميه للاقتصاد العالميه حملتها
صدمات العام 20 22 سلسله ازمات ناقضت
التوقعات السابقه بان 20 22 سيكون عاما من
الازدهار الارتفاع الحاد في الاسعار زياده
معدلات الفائده الاحترار المناخي ازمه
الطاقه الخانقه الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كلها ازمات تنظر بعام قاتم في 20
المؤرخ ادمنتوس اطلق على 20 22 تعبيرا
يلخص ما حدث نحن نتحدث عنا عنوانه هو عام
متعدد الازمات متحدثا عن صدمات متباينه
تتفاعل معا لتجعل الوضع العام في غايه
الصعوبه صدمات بدات وتزايدت منذ بدايه
القرن مع الازمه الماليه عام 2008 ازمه
الديون السياديه
ازمه الطاقه لم يشهد وضع بهذا القدر من
التعقيد منذ الح العالميه الثانيه وفقا
خبراء مشهد اكده بناي رئيس قسم تحليل
الاقتصاد الكلي في اوكسفورد ايكونوميكس في
مقابله مع العربيه اوضح فيها اسباب النظره
تشاؤميه للاقتصاد العالميه
في اكسفورد اسوا من الاراء السائده بشان
نمو الاقتصاد العالمي السنه القادمه نحن
نتوقع ضعفا اكبر وركودا اسود من توقعات
الاخرين لكن اذا نظرنا الى التجارب
التاريخيه هذا الركود سيكون محدودا وسيكون
اصغر من متوسطه الفتره السابقه في التاريخ
[موسيقى]